Eu fui o primeiro e único filho da minha
família por longos e tranquilos sete anos,
embora eu gostasse de ter a atenção dos meus pais só
para mim
, tenho que admitir que era muito solitário, então
quando meus pais me disseram que eu
teria um irmão no hiki, eu  foi
finalmente uma companhia exultante e eu sempre tinha ouvido
minha mãe falando sobre como ela sempre
quis ter uma menina e um menino e
esses seriam seus filhos e então isso
realmente me prendeu eu quando eu acho que
nasceu tudo eu pude parar tudo  Eu podia
pensar que estava tudo bem agora, isso diz que eu e o
ahiki somos todos, sempre estaremos
juntos, mas somos apenas nós, então foi um
grande choque para mim quando dois anos sim em
2015 eu tive um terceiro irmão Reese choroso
e  durante a gravidez da minha mãe,
descobrimos que ele teria síndrome de Down e,
embora estivéssemos muito empolgados em tê-
lo, estávamos com muito medo também, não tínhamos
ideia de como seria ter um
filho com deficiência e nossa família
e nunca tínhamos  entrar em contato com
qualquer pessoa com deficiência para  foi muito
assustador, mas estávamos tão empolgados em tê-lo
e quando ele nasceu percebemos que
não é nem uma deficiência para
nós hoje em dia, apenas vemos isso como algo
que o torna diferente e ele
destruiu completamente todas as nossas
perspectivas e todos os nossos  idéias do
que é ter um filho com deficiência hum
com uma ou mais deficiências e
hoje em dia ele é mais comumente conhecido como
dormindo ou o mais feliz como você
poderia saber então depois disso eu pensei que tudo bem
agora nós terminamos nós deveríamos
ter apenas dois  filhos e agora já
temos três somos uma família muito grande e
felizmente eu estava errado novamente
bem no ano passado estávamos em Boston quando eu
estava fazendo um curso de verão e
decidimos levar meu irmão ao
Hospital Infantil de Boston para ver como  ele estava
fazendo geral para ver como ele estava se
desenvolvendo em comparação com crianças sem a
condição
e nós apenas remarcamos com um
médico, mas no último minuto tivemos que
ser atendidos por outro médico
mal sabíamos disso  t seria uma transição de mudança de vida
quando chegássemos o médico
começou a falar conosco e era realmente
apenas uma conversa fiada como como
você está por que você está aqui você estava de
como é sua rotina familiar e
de repente ela simplesmente virou  ao redor e
olhou para nós diretamente nos olhos e
disse que você é a família que estávamos
procurando naturalmente estávamos um
pouco assustados estávamos muito confusos
mas decidimos ouvir de qualquer maneira e ela
nos disse que recentemente adotou uma
criança  com necessidades especiais e decidiu
defender a causa e então ela
nos mostrou uma página para uma freira para uma ONG que estava
para adoção e doação para crianças com
necessidades especiais e mais especificamente
síndrome de Down mas também outras deficiências e
ela nos mostrou a página para  um garotinho
sob o pseudônimo de Owen e ela é
a da foto à direita e
eu imediatamente nos
apaixonei por ele ele era tão pequeno que não podíamos
deixar de doer para protegê-lo e a partir
daí ela t  nos velhos que ele tinha sido
abandonado ao nascer porque tinha
síndrome de Down ele nunca tinha sido amamentado
ele tinha perdido a chance de ter
uma mãe porque ele tinha síndrome de Down
e que a ideia disso
partiu meu coração completamente porque eu tinha  Eu tinha um
irmão com síndrome de Down e
conhecê-lo todo esse tempo me fez perceber
que isso é realidade para muitas crianças por
aí que são abandonadas por causa de suas
deficiências e a partir daí
decidimos adotá-lo descobrimos acho que duas ou
três semanas  depois disso ele estava a cerca de
6.000 milhas de distância de nós ele estava na
Ucrânia e isso foi pequeno para
nós porque já tínhamos nos apaixonado
por ele ainda
não era nem um grande detalhe para nós e
então como se já não tivéssemos
um dia, tenho crianças suficientes passeando pelo site
e decidi olhar as outras crianças
disponíveis e me deparei com uma garota sob
o pseudônimo de Isabella e ela havia sido
abandonada porque tem espinha bífida
e o que isso significa é para aqueles  de vocês
que sabem o que significa escoliose quando sua
coluna é curta, mas está para fora, então uma
parte de sua coluna está exposta e ela
também foi abandonada por causa de sua
deficiência e ela foi abandonada
no hospital, então o que os médicos
decidiram fazer é nós  vou costurar a
pele dela e mandá-la para um orfanato e
isso também partiu meu coração, então conversei com
minha mãe por alguns dias sem parar e ela
continuou me dizendo que não, já temos
muitos filhos, isso já é demais  muito que seu
pai está fazendo não vai nos deixar fazer isso
e eu insisti mesmo assim então ela nos deixou fazer
isso e eu tenho que admitir que eu sempre
amei tanto meus irmãos mas eu estava meio que
morrendo pela irmã dele então depois disso
foi só  um processo burocrático muito longo
de meus pais viajando para a
Ucrânia e voltando e fazendo a
papelada e voltando para a Ucrânia e
visitando as crianças e um dia quando
finalmente recebemos a ligação e eles nos disseram
que você pode ir para a Ucrânia
e escolher  até seus filhos todo mundo
começa  ed chorando
minha mãe não sabia o que fazer ela estava
tremendo ela estava dizendo que eu tinha que ligar e
pegar as passagens de avião e eu tenho que fazer
as malas dela e eu tenho que fazer tantas coisas
mas no geral foi uma das
mais felizes  dias da minha eu acho que seria
considerado um dos dias mais felizes da
minha vida
hum então depois que nós fomos e
pegamos eles e os trouxemos de volta para o
Brasil eu comecei a pensar em
adotar todo o conceito disso e como eu
nunca tinha  pensei nisso antes de
realmente adotarmos as crianças e pensei
em como isso é realmente uma bagunça.
meus planos eram eu vou
construir minha carreira
vou me casar vou
ter meus filhos e foi aí que me peguei
eu nunca tinha falado pra mim mesma que
vou adotar alguém e eu nunca tinha dito
pra mim mesma  Vou adotar dois
irmãos em  em algum momento da minha vida
porque e isso é porque sempre
temos essa coisa na cabeça de
que seu filho só é seu filho se for
seu filho biológico e isso realmente
me fez pensar nas barreiras da
adoção e como elas funcionam bem primeiro
uma causa mesmo que os EUA tenham o
sistema de acolhimento que é a forma mais barata
de adotar ainda é muito caro para
muitas famílias poderem adotar e
segunda barreira a burocracia na
hora que leva para tudo isso é
simplesmente insano há tão  muita papelada
envolvida e há tanto tempo
envolvido que felizmente só tivemos que passar
por seis meses,
mas para muitas famílias isso acaba sendo de
dois a três anos e isso é embora
valha a pena no final, me fez uma
barreira para algo  para muitas famílias
e estas são apenas duas barreiras entre
tantas que considerei, mas se
há uma barreira que temos que enfrentar
todos os dias e que só
pensei depois que adotei e que quero
t quebrar o hoje que eu quero quebrar
por isso tudo que eu quero
quebrar todos os dias da minha vida é
o da noção preconcebida de que
seu filho só é seu filho se for
seu filho biológico eu só tenho
tempo e eu  só tenho experiência suficiente
para lhe dizer que seu filho é seu
filho se você se der o suficiente se
quando as pessoas nos falam sobre adoção
e sobre o que fizemos eles dizem que você
tem um coração tão grande
que essas crianças têm tanta sorte de ter você
e  Eu continuo dizendo a mim mesmo e continuo
dizendo a eles que temos muita sorte e
não somos apenas nós os adotando, são eles
nos adotando e é sobre todos
dando uns aos outros apenas o suficiente para nos
tornarmos uma família real, mesmo que
haja todos
os tipos de cereais  filhos adotivos não
sendo seus filhos de verdade e eu quero
contar um pouco sobre como tem
sido para nossa família desde que os
adotamos Lucas e na
adoção no primeiro encontro quando
trocamos a fralda dele
nós paramos um  e olhei para ele e ele estava
pele e osso e nos sentimos tão mal porque
ele estava tão mal alimentado e parecia
que não comia há dias
e era ele depois de apenas dez dias
conosco e ele estava rindo ele estava
sorrindo ele  parecia muito mais feliz
do que ele era no primeiro dia
e então ele se adaptou bem rápido Eu
esperava que nosso filho essas crianças demorassem tanto
para se acostumar conosco e para
nós nos acostumarmos com eles, mas acontece
que nós realmente  parecia uma família
desde o primeiro dia e
para Louisa o nome que decidimos
dar à menina que inicialmente estava sob
o pseudônimo de Isabella ela parecia tão
feliz desde o primeiro segundo quando
fomos buscá-la na  o orfanato e
toda vez que ela nos abraça até
hoje ela nos abraça como se entendesse
como nós acabamos salvando
ela porque ela quer dizer eu suponho que desde que
ela é uma criança ela não
necessariamente entende ainda o que isso significa
que a pegamos lá
que nós a trouxemos para um
lugar completamente diferente, mas toda vez que ela a abraça
eu realmente sinto que ela entende
e Lipe acabou se
apegando muito aos dois Luke ele está
absolutamente apaixonado por Lucas ele não entende
no começo ele  não parecia entender
porque tínhamos dois novos filhos na família
e ele estava um pouco ciumento tenho
que admitir mas hoje em dia ele está tão apaixonado
por eles que acho que ele se
tornou dependente deles e os dois
sempre riem  muito tempo quando eles estão um ao lado do
outro e é realmente
muito lindo e no último domingo
29 de janeiro foi
o aniversário de Lisa e decidimos
comemorar o aniversário de Lucas também porque
não tivemos a chance quando estávamos
na Ucrânia e eu só  parei para olhar para
todo mundo e ver como era aquela cena
e eu não vi crianças
que foram adotadas eu vi crianças que estavam
lá o que faz desde o primeiro dia eu vi crianças
que pareciam estar lá
conosco desde sempre  e pessoas  sempre
falei sobre como deve ser tão difícil para as
crianças se reajustarem a uma nova família e eu
não via isso com eles, então, para nossa
experiência, posso dizer com certeza que
não foi difícil, foi uma das
melhores decisões que tomamos.  já fez e
foi absolutamente difícil mudar a vida de
todos nós ter tomado essa decisão e
, com tudo isso, posso dizer que seu
filho não precisa ser biológico para
ser seu filho, se precisamos amá-lo
apenas  por mais que seu filho não precise
ter seu sangue nas veias para você
ser seu filho e para você
amá-lo da mesma forma e isso acaba
sendo uma barreira enorme para muitas pessoas que
querem adotar e sentem vontade  eles
vão enfrentar preconceito ou enfrentar pessoas
julgando-os porque eles a adotaram
porque é assim que não é deles e
eu posso facilmente dizer a você agora que isso
não vai acontecer se você decidir
adotar não por causa dessa palestra do TED, mas
porque  você decide que quer
adotar e porque não vai  o seja uma
decisão maravilhosa para sua família, posso
te dizer que vai ficar tudo bem
e vai ser uma das melhores
decisões que você já tomou há 140
milhões de crianças de acordo com o UNICEF que
estão por aí e que querem e precisam de
pais  há milhões de pessoas por
aí que querem e precisam de filhos, mas não
adotam por causa dessa barreira, então vamos
quebrar essa barreira hoje porque o sangue
é mais grosso que a água,
mesmo que o sangue não seja igual ao
seu, obrigado
[Aplausos]